members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interests
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
have we received any declaration of
interest in advance
a non-received chair
do any other members have an interest to
declare
that's not sure okay
item three minutes of the last meeting
we've now have the minutes of our
meeting held on tuesday the 20th of july
2021
are we happy that they are a correct
record
and so if a mover and a secondary that
so mover is peter elliott secondary is
councillor armitage all those in favor
against we haven't yeah
so there's none against but any
abstentions this is where the hands go
up
thank you
the motion has been
carried main business of today
sorry just for the record that's
councillor cooper councillor foster
councillor hall and councillor hansel
and councillor and councillor top and
councillor hancock thank you
right back to the main business today
that moves us this onto today we have
three substantial items to consider two
items
being tpo tree preservation orders and a
reverse reserved matters application for
a single story dwelling
as you can see each of these
applications has its own report marked
as agendas items four to six
i'm happy with this and intend to
consider them in that order
before we do i would like the clerk to
explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on youtube
how we will deal with the applications
yes thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the applications at the meeting
we will consider the applications in the
order that they are set out on the
agenda
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officer to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and has been to circulated two committee
members
the planning officer will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will share it would be with those
officers attending the meeting remotely
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this
the chat will ask each of the speakers
any objectives then the applicant or
their agent to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
we are reminded given by the clerk when
30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions if necessary to clarify any
points they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee and
determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
a note for the speakers
once the application you've come to
speak on has been dealt with you may
leave the chamber
if you choose to remain
and please not you'll be allowed to
participate further in the meeting from
that point onwards
you will be required to leave the
chamber once the committee has decided
on the application which you've came for
although you may watch watch the rest of
the meeting on a screen elsewhere in the
building if you so
wish as you're aware this meeting is
being recorded and will be placed on the
council's website
the council will use the recording for
the purposes of preparing the minutes
please note however that others may also
record the light um we might also use
this recording which they obtain from
the internet
thank you chair
thank you we can move on to the first
application
the application is to remove two beech
one willow tree and the pruning of one
norway maple tree covered by tpo
preservation order number
280 amended title on the land at the
born
moor road ashover the application number
is ned forward slash two one forward
slash zero zero one two five forward
slash tpo ashover
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning officer alice
lockett to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been
introduced and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans on the site
i will allow the officer to complete the
presentation i asked members to reserve
any points of order or questions about
the process until the end there'll be
plenty of time for your questions later
on
over to alice
you're on you alice
sorry rookie error
um right sorry uh thank you chair may i
first confirm that there are no late
representations um received for this
application this is a tpo application
for the removal of three trees two beach
one willow and the carrying out of work
to one tree a maple at the born moore
road ashoka the curseage of the born can
be seen outlined in orange on this plan
sorry outlined in black and highlighted
in orange
i have outlined the four trees subject
to this application in green on this
plan
members of planning committee attended a
virtual site visit of the site yesterday
where we saw a range of photos of the
site
the detailed arguments for each tree are
outlined in the officer report
this is tree one a beach by the access
gate the proposal is for it to be felled
officers consider that due to the age
and condition of the tree it's lean and
risk the highway and the neighbouring
properties and the damage it is causing
to the boundary wall and the drains at
the born and that these factors outweigh
its contribution to the immunity of the
area
this is another photograph of it taken
from inside the boundary of the born
and that's just one taken a little bit
further away
the next tree is 334 the willow this is
proposed to be failed
officers consider that due to its
condition age and the impact on the
drains and foundations at the born these
factors outweigh its contribution to the
immunity of the area
it's this tree
uh if you want to see it
um
that's just another view of it
and a view of it from um
the highway it's
this one here
tree number eight is a norway maple this
is proposed to be pruned officers
consider that the proposed work is
acceptable and will not damage the
tree's impact on the immunity of the
area
that's a view of it taken from a
marsh green lane
last tree is tree 32 the beach which is
located down in the garden of the barn
this tree is proposed to be felled
however officers consider that the
application has not the applicant has
not shown that this tree is impacting
the drains and foundations of the born
and therefore these factors do not
outweigh its contribution to the
immunity of the area
as such it's considered inappropriate to
fell the tree but permission to carry
out pruning work should be granted
instead
it's just another um another photograph
of it
in summary officers have recommended
part approval part refuse refusal of
this decision
and for the for sorry for the following
reasons
in the case of trees 134 their condition
and the damage they according to the
born out where they outweigh their
contribution to the immunity of the area
in the case of treat the work
proposed is acceptable and will not
impact its contribution to the immunity
of the area
in the case of tree 31 it has not been
shown that the work proposed is
justified and the tree should be pruned
rather than failed
that concludes the presentation thank
you chair
thank you
i believe we have three speakers on this
application
and i will take them in order the first
speaker is an objector alistair petry
if you'd like to take up the table
you have three minutes when you're ready
just press the button in front and it
should come on red
there you
go good afternoon
the report before you proposes that the
majestic beach in this application
should be failed because it is damaging
public utilities
none of the utility companies has
submitted a report advising of a problem
and last month the planning department
determined that an equally large tree
standing in the road just 30 feet away
should be retained
why are the authorities recommendations
not consistent in this respect
the applicant demonstrates damage to a
boundary wall
but that wall could be reconstructed
either side of the tree or realigned
behind it
why is that option not being
pursued tree roots have entered a drain
on the property and it is claimed that
at their extremities roots might damage
foundations
the applicant accepts that in any event
the house needs to be underpinned and
the drains replaced
and with modern materials and techniques
that work can be done in a manner which
is entirely compatible with retaining
the beach
why should this magnificent specimen be
sacrificed when other remedies are
available
the applicant states that the tree is
his property
but he has let it be known in the
community that he does not own the
boundary wall or the trees behind it
which is correct
the tree is 150 years old
but beech trees have a typical lifespan
of 250 years
there is no independent professional
evidence that this tree is in poor
health or that it is dangerous
why cut its life span short contrary to
your environmental policies
when that act is avoidable
the beach should be retained
but if you were to permit its removal
why are you not able to recover to the
public purse its lost amenity value as
do other authorities
tree eight the maple
stands on land for which there is sound
evidence of it being public highway
rather than private garden
what steps have you taken with the
county highway department
to verify the proper ownership of that
strip of land and the ownership of the
tree
your case officer states that the maple
is healthy and of a good shape
why prune it
why can it not be left in this rural
setting to develop its natural form
30 seconds remain your parks department
has no objection to a maximum 20 pruning
of this tree but your officer recommends
a one-third crown reduction and a 20
pruning this would remove most of the
foliage from which much of the
environmental benefit is gained why does
your officer go well beyond the
recommendation of the parks department
i submit that these matters have not
been investigated adequately
that the removal of the beach and the
pruning of t8 and t32 are not justified
excuse me your three minutes are up
just t34 the willow
thank you thank you are there any
questions for the speaker councillor
foster
thank you mr peter um
my question is regarding the condition
it's in one of the reports by an ashover
tree warden that the trees past its best
i've driven past and seen the tree
myself it looks in good condition as
i've seen it but i've only seen it at
this time of year and obviously trees
change obviously throughout the year i
wondered if you could give us just your
opinion uh as i'm guessing your local
master yeah to it your opinion on the
condition of the tree throughout the
year
please
i would say it's a fine specimen there's
no obvious evidence of any significant
uh sickness or defect or
branches that are dying or
losing their leave cover it appears
to be in very good health
one of the things that surprises me is
that
the council doesn't feel it necessary to
employ an independent uh
arboriculturalist to form a view about
these matters
uh
it seems to me that
uh relying on the arbor
culturalist of the applicant
is likely to
lead to
a biased view
but but to answer your question
i see nothing about the tree that
suggests it's
sick in any way whatsoever
thank you mr pedro
council armitage
thank you
perhaps you could
uh tell us a bit more about the maple
being on the public highway because
according to the plan that we've been
given
it's in the uh precinct of the building
the
the map that uh is on the back of
the officer's report from the highway
authority
is clearly their current map of the of
the highway
however
these maps produced by the hawaii
department have been done during the
tenure of the highways by the county
council
and uh they were prepared without
capturing the history of the creation of
these roads originally the roads were
managed by the parish and then the
responsibility transferred to the rural
district council
and only
after that did it transfer to the county
council and there was virtually no
history transferred
with it so these maps
tend to show
what is on the ground not necessarily
what is technically the correct
extent of the highway
now
in respect of this the part of marsh
green lane which bounds on the bourne
um it was set up under the enclosure act
which is very very fully documented in
the county
archives the county record office at
matlock and it's very clear that it was
set up as a 40-foot
highway
in
perpetuity um
and that obviously would have happened
at that time but at some time after it
was set up
land has been taken back into the garden
of the born such that the stretch of
highway in question now in places is as
little as 16 feet wide
rather than the 40 feet that its
statutory width
now
there is a process in law whereby you
can enclose
private land and if it's not objected to
after a period of time you can acquire a
legal right to it but that doesn't exist
with highways once a highway has been
set up
putting a boundary around it and closing
it in some way and trying to take it
into private land
has no legal validity so there is a very
wide strip of land within the grounds of
the born that is strictly still highway
and that includes a bit that the maple's
on
councillor lickett
good afternoon and there's a question
about the beach tree i noticed it
obviously there's a slight lean on it am
i thinking that that's prevailing
westerly wind
behind that i'm just i'm just presuming
that that lean has been there since it
was a baby
um
yes i've never i've lived in my screen
name for 40 years now
the tree hasn't moved in 40 years it's
always had a lean like that it's a very
limited lane it's a few degrees that's i
was just thinking because obviously
that's that's facing west isn't it so
the prevailing wind probably just blew
it slightly when it was a baby it could
be the effect of the prevailing wind or
i i don't know but whatever has done it
it seems to be perfectly stable all
right thank you
council
uh i'm looking at the tree and i'd have
to say it looks like it's got a
significant lean but in your opinion
with a better crown or part
i don't think it's necessary to do
anything to it quite honestly i don't
believe it is dangerous nobody's claimed
that it's dangerous
um
it's stable
it's in good health
a lead of a few degrees on the tree is
nothing you see some trees that have
tremendous lean on them um and they have
the ability to to withstand it
i think the very fact that it's growth
yeah i'm surprised in the office's
report she says it can't be the wall
couldn't be built outside the tree
because the highway wouldn't accept a
reduction in the width of the lane and i
think that's perfectly reasonable but
there's absolutely no reason why the
wall couldn't be realigned behind the
tree or indeed it could just have a
breach in it it could be dismantled and
built close up either side of the tree
looking at it on the picture in front of
it only lead mold and banking anyway so
i'm sure it could they could actually
build it's 16 10 inches and to keep that
to keep how
heritage is
so yeah
thank you
are there any further questions
no thank you
and the next speaker we have is a
supporter peter brabing
that's okay take your time
three minutes when you're ready
thank you chair for affording me the
opportunity to speak to the committee
i refer you to my letter
to the
planning officer 2nd of march this year
which we'll have seen and
for more extensive detail
my sole focus is regarding this
application with specific reference to
the beech tree
at the entrance to the born on moore
road ashore which does present a danger
to properties
and to life and limb and should i
believe be removed on health and safety
grounds
my house lies directly under that
leaning tree
the following reasons it condition
it is leaning approximately 30 degrees
over the road and properties
mine close by driven by a southwesterly
wind being supported by a five-foot
boundary wall
as the pressure of the wall increased
over time it split on one side of the
tree from top to bottom and this split
has widened year on year
worryingly now a second
crack has appeared the other side of the
trunk of the tree creating a slab of
wall leaning with the tree and offering
little support for the tree
it's size it's a huge tree
gigantic over 80 feet tall
it says well over 150 years of age and
coming to its natural life span
its position over hanging moore road a
busy public road an adjacent properties
as i said mine being the closest
all the walls of
on the wall of the um
houses a pulse box close by
attracting people into the danger area
for these reasons i believe it's
critical health and safety issue that
requires its urgent removal
on a personal level my wife and i have
lived in the house closest to the said
tree for 43 years and have observed and
monitored its decline quite frankly the
threat and worry that this tree has
posed us has blighted our lives
my wife now 83 will not sleep in the
front master bedroom anymore because of
the threat of the trees falling and
demolishing the house
it has added to her depression
i understand those are objects on
ecological grounds and preservation
issues but it is my belief 30 seconds on
the health and safety issue outweigh
those considerations i do support those
such considerations however so that i
will be willing to replace the said
beach tree with two saplings in a more
appropriate position i believe that the
committee has received the
recommendation that that tree be removed
on health and safety grounds i
respectfully urge the committee to
endorse his recommendation thank you
chair and ladies and gentlemen of the
committee for your forbearance
thank you are there any questions
no thank you mr bobbing
[Music]
we have one final speaker on this
application and that's the agent bill
anderson
three minutes when you're ready miss
james thank you i didn't really have
anything to say but i thought i'd better
address some of the objections
um
the problem with rebuilding a wall in
close proximity to a tree is whether you
can do it mature trees whether you can
do it without damaging the roots it
would be ridiculous to rebuild the wall
quite close by if the digging of the
foundations led to damage to the roots
infection decay and then you got to
remove it anyway
um
well i can't disagree that beech trees
live for considerably longer than this
one most beech trees don't live for even
half this tree's lifespan i
reject any suggestion that it's only of
average age it's well above average age
um the idea that somebody should be
obliged to pay
the amenity value of the tree
to the local authority because it's
had to be removed
just i find it completely mystifying and
i disagree entirely
and really i don't think i've got
anything else to say but if you've got
any questions i'd be happy to help
are there any questions counselor foster
thank you mr anderson uh when he comes
we've heard quite a few times now
about the age
of beech trees yeah when um and in all
beech trees are different some can die
earlier some can last something lasts
longer but you when you look at how it's
actually weighted uh
how they're rated by the woodland
75 to 150 years is notable veteran is
125 to 200 an ancient is 225 years
onwards now we don't expect every tree
to get to to be an ancient tree at all
but this one is reckoned to be in the
office's report between 120 and 150 that
only puts it just in
the first
that first portion
which is notable
uh so
i suppose my question to you is
uh how old do you think the tree is and
what what's your uh
sorry yeah what's your take on it's on
its condition uh there's a forestry
commission research note that works out
the age of
trees that are beyond you know um
mature
and i worked it out at 150 and i think
that's what alice is referring to when
she said that somebody else did it at
120. it could be anywhere i would say
that
it would coincide with the age of the
house because it just seems to make
sense
um the woodland trust figures
while i don't doubt what they say about
ancient and veteran trees and notable
trees most trees don't even make notable
you know it's just a fact of life it's
just like you know humans sheep anything
else
most trees just reach average you know
and the average is depressingly low or
impressively low whichever way you look
at it
i suppose what i'm trying to get at mr
anderson is that
some trees do reach notable some after
that rich veteran and then ancient yeah
and it's about the condition of this
treat to me it looks like it's from what
i've seen of it and what i've asked one
of the previous um
speakers
is that it looks like it to me it looks
like it is notable and it could go
further it doesn't look like it's in
poor condition
we didn't say it was in poor condition
and
you know i would dispute that it's
notable i think you'll find a lot of
beech trees similar to that one
i'll i'll finish on this last one the
notable is what's given by woodland
trustees how they grade them yes it's
all about age yeah so it's so if it is
120 to 150 it puts it in notable yeah
but there's a lot of trees that are
notable around then it's not that
notable
okay thank you i've got three speakers
waiting so councillor armitage
councillor ridgeway then councillor
councillor armitage thank you chair uh
you seem to speak with uh
some
knowledge of trees are you
a qualified expert on uh trees i hold a
professional diploma in arboriculture
from the royal forestry society right
thank you
councillor ridgeway
yeah do you have any idea how long the
wall has been up because it sounds like
the tree's been there longer than the
wall
i would um
i don't know how you draw that
conclusion i would have said the wall
was the same age as the house wouldn't
you
i don't know that's why i'm asking the
question
okay councillor liggett then councillor
jones
um
if you can to answer these many
questions about ownership
i can't i know nothing i assumed it was
my client's trees that's all i can say
about and also about the wall um i know
it's not a dry stone wall
but surely it could be built back as a
dry stone wall so then the rooms
wouldn't be damaged at all
i would just thought it still needed a
foundation and you know it is
it's my experience that lots of efforts
to build
i can't say a lot because i don't see
that many but
efforts to build
um close by
mature trees
are
it's always a toss-up whether you're
going to win or not
well i know i know dry stone walls
definitely don't need a foundation you
just start at ground level
counselor jones
[Music]
yeah about the wall again
it's difficult as you say because of
foundations but why can't the wall be
terminated at each side of the tree
so the tree fills the gap
and apparently we were led to believe
that it was on some kind of bank
but after looking at it i believe it's
actually going right down into the
ground it's not on the bank as such
so therefore
i don't see why they can't just
take the wall that's falling down
and make it each side
um
i have no opinion on that i'm sorry i
haven't even considered it i just
thought that the wall wanted to be put
back to where it belonged
you know i have suggested to numerous
highway authorities that they allow
people to build their walls out into the
road and even when there is plenty of
space which there isn't here
then uh you know the highway authority
are invariably not in favor
and as i say you could apply the
principle of the root protection area
which
you know if you follow the british
standard for that that's 5837
2012.
then the root protection area for that
tree would be a circle of
20 meters radius with the tree in the
middle and you shouldn't do any building
work within that 20 meters you know
we've stuck with the problem that we've
no idea where that tree's grown its
roots we assume it's not doing much
underneath the road but the driveway to
the bone and everything else must have
diverted root growth
we really haven't got a clue what might
happen if we start trying to do any sort
of wall foundations and to say i don't
know about dry stone ones i'm not my
field
counselor
just a question we were led to believe
that the roots of this tree are in the
sewers
yes how do we know it's that tree
because that garden is full of trees
um again i presume they've been
identified but usually it's the nearest
are there any further questions
councillor hancock
thank you chair um
obviously based on on your qualification
here um i'll be honest i'm kind of
losing confidence that we've actually
got a definitive idea as to why this
tree is particularly one that needs to
be removed so can you kind of reiterate
for me
why you think this this actual tree
needs to be needs to be taken out
because i'm
i'm boarding massively on uncertainty
here um
well no i can't you know i mean
as i say i don't think that you could
seriously rebuild that wall to the
standard that it was built before it was
cracked by the tree without causing
damage to the tree
the tree's already got one or two wounds
on the trunk due to it rubbing against
the wall and i accept that these this
rubbing is microscopic but nonetheless
it leads to wounds and you know elderly
trees by definition are less resistant
to disease infection and decay than the
young tree you know if it was a young
tree then perhaps we just still
dig the foundation put the wall and
we'll see what happens but
you know at the end of it
um
it is not a tree with a long future life
almost certainly
um and i think it would be a waste of
time taking steps to try and
preserve it when the chances of success
you know the chance any steps you did
you did take if you know it would be
expensive and throwing good money after
that just doesn't sound like a sensible
option
and
i mean realistically
based on what we've heard the chances
are it's actually got a longer lifespan
than any of us in this room
so
i wouldn't rely on that if i were you
young man
well well no this is the thing because i
mean we're hearing
we're hearing that there is no kind of
evidence of disease to it um there's a
few cracks which we've been told which
have have got progressively worse but
i've seen trees that are pretty much
hollowed out and still surviving quite
quite well
so that this is this is a bit i'm not
kind of getting my head around as to why
there's a recommendation beyond it
purely being around this wall well
one um
those hollow trees
you won't find anybody who's going to
guarantee that they're going to stand up
we know that they stand up for a long
time
equally we know that some trees don't
stand up despite being perfectly solid
you know in this instance there's a lot
of disturbance going on
around there there's already
excavations for the underpinning and
drain repairs and everything you know
you just have to consider what's likely
to happen
um i've been in this industry for 40
years now and what you usually find with
big mature beech trees is they'll get a
fungus called miripolis giganteus you
might have seen this it's a massive
fruiting body and you'll find it at the
bottom of elderly beech trees and i mean
this decays roots usually the tree will
start to die back
but
you know lots of trees that i thought
would see me out already haven't
um i just wouldn't
put money on any tree
making it to veteran you know
having it having made it to this age i
think is impressive
but realistically there's no evidence of
anything of that nature apart from a
dirty great crack in the world there's
nothing wrong with the tree
are there any further questions
thank you if you'd like to take your
seat
you will now have the opportunity to put
questions to the officer about this
application
again i would like to keep this part of
our proceedings focused on getting
clarity
about any of the points you're not sure
of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all we have heard and read
i would be grateful if you could not
move any motions at this stage let's
wait until we have a chance to make our
own assessments thank you are there any
questions right council elliott then
councillor liggett
yes
i'm sorry i couldn't hear that i
couldn't hear anything
sorry
i'll try again alice is that better oh
yes that's much better yes thank you
could you just
sorry just give us a a bit of an idea
the
officers that attended site no
these are saying that it should be
removed but have they got the knowledge
have we had an independent survey on it
to say whether or not it needs to be
removed because even the
even the previous uh chap speaking was
saying that it's the wall that's cracked
and nothing to do with the tree
um so i visited the site and um
martin uh who used to work in parks
visited the site he's got a lot of
experience in trees
uh he
said he found some evidence of fishes
and cavities in the top of the tree that
haven't been mentioned
by they hadn't actually been mentioned
in the report but he spotted those
um
he considered you know the thing is is
that we're balancing
the the
condition of the tree against the risk
of um
and it's sorry the condition of the tree
and its impact on the immunity of the
area against the risk of its damaging
the wall the highway the um the houses
on the other side and the um
the drains at the born so
i you know yeah that appears to be well
according to martin he was under the
impression that there was some
um
disease possibly or or potential for
disease in the tree
um
but also
you know when when you're looking at it
in balanced against all those other
things that's that's what we were
we were
considering does that happen is that
enough
yeah
thanks alice yeah it is enough but i've
got to say that a tree and this has
nothing to do with this application but
i'm just trying to make the equation a
tree in one of my local villages they
said you know 10 years ago we should
have fetched it down the tree is still
beautiful the canopy is still fantastic
every year
yeah
when i'm long gone i've no doubt i'm
sure you're right and but we have to
take each one on its merits don't we and
and
balance
that against against the other factors
which is what we've done in our
recommendation
from a litigation perspective i guess
yeah
thank you
councillor
good afternoon alice um a question about
ownership can you hear me all right yeah
i can yeah
question about ownership that kim seems
to keep coming up in
what we're talking about
and also just a comment because i like
councillor elliot do know that tree and
i i walk past there there's a footpath
and i go pretty
numerous times of the year and i must
admit to say it's supposed to be
dangerous an awful lot of people park
their cars on that road
underneath that tree during storms and
wind and all sorts that we've walked
um they don't seem that concerned or
else i don't think we'd be parking there
but mainly it's about this ownership
because i don't really see how any of us
can
say anything if we don't know who owns
it
well um i think we just have to as with
all planning applications we take this
on the merit
on what we're told by the applicant and
the the applicant stated he did own the
trees
um
in in the application form when we had
the question from mr petry we did
question him about that and he produced
that that
map that's in your um
in in your pack that shows what the
boundaries of the highway are as far as
we're concerned uh we
that that's that's accepted and that he
does own the trees i mean if he's if
he's saying he doesn't then that's a
different um
a different situation but as far as
we're concerned he does own the trees
and he does have the right to carry out
the work to them as it is with tpo
applications you can actually
put in an application for work on a tree
you don't own however you do have to
tell us that and you have to serve
notice on the person that who does own
it
but in this case the highways of
happy about the the boundaries of the
born
the only other question i've got for you
is the the field maple
can i ask why that that's going to be
pruned or they're wanting to prune it
i think they just
are trying to start a program of
carrying out um
good maintenance to the trees at the
board and i think it's um
been said a number of times
that the previous owner of the born
really didn't carry out any work and
that's probably why we've got to
situation particularly with the willow
tree that it's you know it's in it's in
not a very good condition
um
so
as i understand it they want to start a
program of just taking a little bit more
responsibility for their trees
so this came in as part of this
application there's never been a
question a mark about felling this tree
it was only ever about um about carrying
out some pruning work to it
thank you
councillor foster
thank you chair
my question is about the report um in
the papers at 4.1
from the ash over tree warden uh just a
bit of clarity uh
beyond this
um as i read through this report
we make the assumption the number
number one beech tree uh is a tree
that's past its best
uh it talks about the willow probably
not intended to be there and then it
talks about beach number 32 could could
be problematic and then later on a time
to replace and change planting and then
further on at the end but that's past
the mark and it's time to grow something
else i'm concerned about how much weight
here
we put on this report
um so my question really to officers uh
as well as the actual detail of itself
who is this ash of a tree warden who
employs them what organization are they
part of who appoints them
and i'm concerned about how much weight
we give this a as a committee
it's not like it's uh
to me it doesn't look like one of the
usual tree reports we get from
either a second requested
uh tree report or one from our own
um
tree department
opinion on that please
i actually um
don't know exactly i believe that they
are
employed or
connected to the parish council
but perhaps councillor armitage can
confirm that
um
is that right cancer armitage
no
i think it was in july last year that
the tree group uh
were sort of uh taken away from the uh
irish council and the parish council so
with its uh tied to them
uh okay
so that that is uh as it is at the
moment
as for qualifications well i'm not sure
that the tree one has any but
i i know she's been on a course because
she went on the same course as myself
but that's all i know
as i understand that tree wardens are
volunteers who uh volunteer for the
parishes that they live in to
keep an eye on trees they have as
councilors says some training
and um
they can report issues to trees to to us
or to the parish
um but they're not necessarily um tree
experts
um as far as we're concerned we always
consult a tree warden if there is one
within the parish where the tree is um
situated
and
we
we put i mean obviously we take some
notice of what they say we don't
completely disregard it but we make sure
that we've
um
you know
got the the um
evidence from the
the experts as well which in this case
would be our own tree person
and the um
the survey from the applicant's um
qualified tree surgeon
councillor foster
thank you chair yeah perhaps when you've
said that not necessarily tree experts
perhaps
as a committee we should consider how
much weight we put on this report when
we consider it when we compare it to our
own tree experts so that's what i'm
trying to get out it's all in writing
and it looks like it's a tree warden and
they might well have got a qualification
or some education in it but it's for me
it's who regulates them who appoints
them and what interest do they have uh
and it's that it's that inclusion that
report within this that i'm concerned
about and if like you say they're not
necessarily experts tree experts you
stated that's my concern not necessarily
tree ex tree expert but i i haven't
quoted them in my report apart from
within this section of the comments
so when it comes to quoting
um
you know making quotes about um the tree
that's all been the stuff that our parks
people
sent to us
so i wouldn't i wouldn't i don't think i
would quote the tree warden
as evidence in that sense if you see
what i mean
thank you that's correct just um
add that um
what uh um alice is saying there is
correct i mean the um
uh the ashover tree warden comments just
need to be taken on on face value it is
the um uh the council's parks
departments who are advising the local
planning authority on this and those are
the um
the
consultation responses that we are
relying on largely in
making the recommendation that we are
thank you
thank you are there any further
questions
counselor hancock
thank you chair um it's just one because
we keep having the words potential and
possible use an awful lot um but we've
had
contradictory accounts of of the the
lean of this this tree
um what is the likelihood that it
actually does present a genuine threat
to the properties over over the road
it's a tall tree and it's leaning
with any tree we have no guarantee that
it's going to stay up i mean a tree even
a tree that's
that's
perfectly vertical
you can't guarantee that it's going to
stay up so
it's always about risk and probability
um
i don't think i can tell you one way or
the other but if it does fall i think
it's got a good chance of causing damage
to the properties over the road
or at the very least being you know
causing a lot of hassle on the you know
the this to the highways but i would
think it would impact the properties as
well
but like i say it
we can't we can't guarantee that it will
stay up or that it will fall but we've
just got to get um
balance the probability and the risk
and the impact with respect though
that's what i'm actually asking you to
do because we keep spending potential
and possibility but
it's all very very speculative we're
getting no kind of of guys i mean
the fact that we know is it stood for at
least 120 years that angle has been
there for a significant part of that so
i'm asking for context on that
so
as i've explained in
as i've outlined in the report and
explained i think already
we look we're balancing
the risks of if that tree does fall
against the
impact on the immunity and the
likelihood of its falling i would say
personally
with
some knowledge of trees but
a tree that's got a lean like that has
probably and and of the age it is and
clearly that wall is is
is moving so that could have an impact
on the roots uh that there is a higher
risk of it falling but i i couldn't tell
you that it will or when it will
that's for
you know that
in my opinion giving my advice to you
i think that the risk of it falling
outweighs the um and the risk to the
other the other issues to the drains to
the bone itself which is a heritage
asset um
i think that that outweighs the
impact of that tree on the immunity of
the area now you know that's my
officer opinion
and
you are obviously
able to to to disagree with that that's
that's what we're here for if that's
what you choose to do
but i you know
the the
the process that i've gone through has
come has taken me to the conclusion that
the fouling of the tree is appropriate
no thank you i'm not disagreeing with
them i'm simply asking for clarity so i
can reach a decision that's all thank
you
thank you are there any further
questions
thank you alice
okay we're at the stage where we can i
can open the floor to debate
um
this leads us to the final part of the
process
and our discussion will be heard and
that we think and want to decide but
before going any further i would just
like the clerk to remind us about
motions
yes thank you chair
uh please burn in mind
that a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false or in other words
it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you chair
thank you
um as the clerks just reminded us could
you please refrain from moving any
motions till everyone's had a chance to
speak if they wish to and i'm going to
now open the floor
wow
counselor armitage then counselor bow
[Music]
thank you council armitage i know that
really you just want the last word
and we've we've really been
concentrating on one tree here we
not the whole
application
there is only one thing in my mind that
has any value in terms of how i make a
decision and that is
that the safety is of paramount
importance
um i think the safety of people far
outweighs the amenity value of a tree
i think council hancock whilst raising
the question
to the officer about clarity
you know we we we are off it's often
said these days because of climate
change and whatever
um things that are once in 100 or 200
years are now becoming almost regular
um and i've got personal experience of a
of a wall and a tree
to me
um
the wall is unsafe
and that could damage
either people or property
um and i think the tree um is
potentially unsafe
um
not just because of its
30 30 degree lean
uh but simply um that it's proximity to
the highway and i also am very persuaded
by the argument
of the person who lives opposite um and
clearly
it has affected his and his wife's life
to to a great degree in which i i
sincerely regret
i would hate to be sitting here in a
year or five years time
uh and to be told that this trio of this
wall had fallen
and we had taken the decision that well
it'll be okay
um so that's where i'm coming from i am
deeply deeply concerned about safety
thank you
thank you councilman armitage
yeah uh thank you chair
yes the
no one can predict if a tree is going to
fall or not and
you know this is obviously a difficult
one and this is one of the reasons why i
asked for
a committee to
rule on it
as far as i'm concerned that
the main tree
is the willow which has been allowed to
uh get covered in ivy like many of them
of the trees around ashore
and it's become choked there's been
little or no maintenance on any of the
trees in that air in the area
as regards the other beech tree well i
can't see a problem with that
it's there it's a long way from the
house so it can't possibly be
causing any problem
there's been a lot of speculation uh
about who owns the wall well i spoke to
mr robinson the owner
and he categorically told me he did not
own the wall it was still owned by the
previous uh
owners of the property
uh
so on that i you know i would like it to
be minuted that that is what the
gentleman said to me
uh
well uh
the
maple
well we had mr petry tell you uh about
it
whether they only or not
as far as i'm concerned
if you go back to the highway
act and it should be what was it 40 feet
wide well it certainly isn't there uh up
to the wall edge but we've got just the
thing
the plan which has been given to us
which says that it is now
i'm of two minds it doesn't need uh
pruning as far as i'm concerned let it
grow as it wants the thing which the
uh
no one's mentioned
about
global warming
now
these trees
are doing quite a good job of
offsetting this
this council
has got has
gone along with an emergency plan
because of global warming and it's no
good felling trees left right and center
especially ones with tpos on them
and as far as i'm concerned the only
tree that needs falling is the willow
thank you chair
thank you councillor hancock
thank you chair um i actually do agree
with councillor powell and thank you to
alice for clarifying that last bit um it
rips my heart out to even consider
failing any but i i do have sufficient
concerns over the safety of that one
beach that i think perhaps
um it would be most appropriate in the
circumstances likewise i agree with
councillor armitage
over over the the willow um i i don't
think there's any justification at all
to touch the other two in any way shape
or form um but i i do have and alice has
convinced me
i i'm i'm con
i'm sufficiently concerned about that
beach by the wall that there
is potential for an ongoing problem and
i think
we we would be remiss not to take action
on that one if i'm honest
counselor elliott
completely agree with everything that's
been said i agree with councillor
armitage uh you know i i'd hate to see
it come down i'm like you david
i really am not
not for knocking anything down or trees
down that need to come down but
i'm i'm absolutely with councillor
powell that if it's a safety issue and
it's a safety issue for neighbours or
the road or anybody around it walking
under it cars parked under it
we just don't know and i'm with you that
i wouldn't want to sit here in five
years time and think we've been remiss
at not letting that come down
the willow is choked i agree that can
come down and 25 pollarding on the other
beach on 34 again can be done
and much as it hurts me to say the same
as you david i think we do need to if it
can't be crowned and pollarded and
brought down to us you know a reasonable
height then it doesn't need to come down
but i would like to say if if we do take
that stance you know the government
right now got a policy on planting trees
i'd like to see some substantial trees
put back in its place not saplings we've
got to wait 150 years to see them
grow and decide whether they're going to
fall again thank you councillor ridgeway
then councillor foster yeah council
elliot just um
said everything uh i was going to add
you know we do need to if we knock that
tree down that it is replaced with this
one or two substantial mature trees
uh and again looking at where it can't
cause any damage and i do think if the
willow's coming down maybe it could be
could something else be put in its place
somewhere else as well maybe another
willow
and we shouldn't just be chopping trees
down willy-nilly but i do agree on the
safety aspect of things but i am all for
keeping the trees as long as we can
councillor foster thank you chair um
yeah
when it comes to beech tree number one
i'm not convinced uh it is such a danger
uh there's a danger with any of those
trees in high winds with all trees but
i'm not convinced this is a specific
danger
i don't think it's reached that uh that
level for me there's cars around it
there's uh houses around it and i do
understand that uh but it's a tree that
there's that mr anderson said uh is
there's nothing wrong with the tree
apart from the crack in the wall
you know uh that wall's moved as the
tree's grown
um
if it's not
and i i've seen it i've driven past it
if it is as it is it doesn't look like a
30 degree lean at all
at all there's no 30 degrees there
um you know
very few trees grow straight up very few
trees do the nearly all trees grow at an
angle
and it looks like unless somebody said
this tree is leaning i just assume
that's a normal tree that's heading
towards the sky at an angle but like all
trees so i don't think it's
a tree that's leaning it's healthy it
doesn't look like it's coming down it's
like any tree that's near a property to
me any other tree
if we look at where we live ourselves
and think about trees that are around
our own houses you know just because the
slight lean on a tree and you know it
doesn't mean it's coming down
but
i do understand it from people that have
spoken i take the point that is about
balancing risk this can reward like
everything else but for me that barrier
has not been reached it might have done
for other people but for my own it's a
tree that's standing up it's healthy
strong
and it doesn't look like it's any
particular danger to anyone
if we consider about chopping all trees
down they've got a slight lean on them
throughout the whole district do you
know
so that that's my take on it uh and i do
understand the
uh the point made by uh
councillor powell that it does compare
mental health health and safety must do
i do understand that but for me to not
reach that level perfect for myself
counselor liggett
yeah i'm afraid i'm going to agree with
councillor foster um and also i'd like
the committee to take into account
because it is relevant
what's happening with our other trees
locally the horse chestnut disease and
the ash dieback because i think within
10 years i think derby should be very
lucky if we have either of those two so
we keep taking out extra trees
that aren't diseased i think it's going
to be very sad and i think if we do come
to a conclusion that any of these trees
has got to come out particularly
obviously the willow
is not here now there is it's been
choked but i do believe that we should
ask for replacements
but i feel very strongly about taking
out a tree that is still alive when
there are so many of dying rounders
thanks chad i'm also um a tad worried
about you know the discussion about who
owns the wall so if you give them
permission to take the tree down who's
going to repair that because an issue
for me is not only the tree leaning and
i agree with what mark's saying about
the lean
an issue just as big an issue is the
risk of the wall falling over
so who if if the tree does come down
who's going to repair the wall we're
going to have a decision on who owns it
so they can come and repair it
can it you know can the footings can it
be dug out carefully and footings be put
in over it and bridge it so you don't
ruin the tree and the tree can stay up i
think there's
still plenty of questions to be asked
it's a difficult one
any other comment
counselor armitage yeah just to come
back on
the fact that uh
what uh peter elliott said the uh there
was a tree uh with the tpo on it on the
other side of marsh lane
and
a drain was laid
well it was within the uh
root protection area but
it was
it was that the pipes were put
under the roots because the roots are
near the were near the surface and it
was taken out very carefully
the enforcement officer
was allowed to come and have a look he
had a look before uh and after and he
was okay with the way it had been done
and
the tree is still standing so
uh
as for regards sort of cutting them uh
to put
a foundation in well it can be done
without damaging the roots as was shown
earlier and in fact uh it was a drain
that mr petry put in
and it was okayed by the uh enforcement
officer and it had been done correctly
uh if we go
back to we had a similar uh occurrence
with a big tree in the cemetery
and what we did there that was you know
how do we do it how do we do it without
damaging the roots well what we did uh
we cleaned the sides of the wall out and
we put a poston rail around it and that
sufficed
so it can be done
thank you councillor hall and then i'm
going to open the floor for motion thank
you it seems that there's quite a bit of
concern about the uh beech tree
uh
that's pushing the wall over but
sometimes in the past we have had
independent reports done before we do
grant permission or anything like that
is it a valid point to try and get one
done this time to say
um
not not adjourned uh
defer deferred
until the report is done maybe
okay thank you now i'm going to open for
emotion
if anyone wants to
counsel a ridgeway
fingers poised yes i i actually agree
with councillor hall there i think
there's so many questions that need to
be asked like who owns the wall if if
it's still the previous owner then you
know we need to get some clarification
on that and i think we need to have a
proper independent review on this tree
on its health and everything and what
damage it could or couldn't cause
so i actually feel that we should be
going for a deferment and bringing this
back to the planning committee
thank you have i a seconder
councillor hancock and councillor hall
i have show of hands please
um
we would normally actually do this um by
um
so just to be clear chair then um the um
motion is that the application be
deferred
pending uh further information in terms
of the ownership of the wall and
surroundings
and uh also for a independent review um
of the the tree to take place by an up
well
expert i think for the the health of the
tree and for the health of the tree yeah
and maybe getting the highways involved
i think we need to have a lot more
information from a lot of different
parties before we can sit and make a
decision on this particular tree
uh has the surrey chair through you as
the planning service any uh views on
that or comments
i just like to um to say
that
clearly as far as an independent
view in relatio of the trees is
concerned
the advice we get from the parks team
is independent in as much as
we we are looking for independent advice
we're not looking for advice to direct
um a view one way or another we're
certainly looking at independent device
and as we have
seen in uh in other cases um
recently
um
all the uh that
is done that when we do go out to get
further advice once we have uh
identified a uh consultant to come back
and to give uh additional advice we're
pretty much um seem to be agreeing with
what our
parks department team
uh are able to advise us
so clearly it is
the council's
um tree advisors who are giving us this
advice and that is independent so you we
already have independent advice that is
being used to to advise you on the
recommendation
did you hear that richard
do we have any comments on the ownership
regarding the wall
well in in relation to the ownership um
clear clearly
um
as uh
um alice has already advised and as you
know from um
the
common way of dealing with planet
applications
that we've been given advice about uh
um who owns who owns what and we take
that on on face value
now
if if there is a
a need
um
that
there's a another owner that um is
identified further on down the uh
the
um the line
then it is for the person carrying out
the works to get the agreement of that
owner
um as a local planning authority
uh we have done what we need to do
in terms of uh asking the question and
we have been given an answer
and that would usually be enough for us
to uh proceed to make a decision
thank you councillor foster then
councillor liggett
thank you chair i'd like to support the
comments of our officer mr basil uh
i've made this point before at uh
committee
it's all well and good asking for uh no
disrespect so all in good asking for a
second opinion or a professional
uh report on trees but we have that with
our own department parks department and
i've always been willing to trust our
own workers they're qualified they know
the job
and that's why very often the the second
opinion or professional opinion is it is
being called you know will say the same
thing so i'd like to put faith in what
our own offices
have given us and that's on the the the
just solely on the tree report i've made
that point before you know it's all in
there in writing uh we've even had uh
reports uh from uh from mr anderson
which pretty much say the same thing
if if if a decision is difficult to make
and it is a difficult decision for a lot
of a lot of us here if it's difficult
we can't just push it onto one side we
have to we have to make a decision we
owe it
to people here to make that decision
if the only reason for me for deferring
something if if it's extra advice for
example if it's something to do with the
wall if we need to know who owns that
wall that'll take but not the actual
point of we need another opinion on the
trees because we've got that from our
own parts department
thank you chair
i was just going to ask richard purcell
richard could you tell me the parks
department have they got our
arboricultural qualifications
um
well they they do have two
um
specialist tree officers within the past
the the people we're asking are not um
uh
lawnmower operatives or something like
that they are people who
are employed as um three officers within
the parks team i can't quote to you
their specific qualifications in um of
each of them but um
they are uh reliable and um
well-informed
independent advisors that we um that we
do draw and
regulate
so you can't tell me that the chap that
went out i think is retired doesn't he
now but you can't tell me whether he's
got other
arboric cultural qualifications
i i
i don't know offhand exactly what
qualifications um he has no i can't tell
you that
counselor hancock
thank you chair um just just pick up
because totally respect what council
foster and richard have said i think
that the key thing is we have got
slightly
different opinions here in terms of
what's been said because we've said
there might be infection there might be
this i think we just need clarification
that as to what the actual position is
so i'd be comfortable on that
just
yeah i'd just like to support what
counselor foster says my view is that
it really worries me when we start to
question the ability and competence of
our own offices
we have done enough on this if we defer
it
we will have the same debate all over
again and i don't think it will it will
make any difference to the final outcome
i have absolute confidence in our
office's ability
to present us
an accurate report
yeah uh thank you chair
as
regards uh this uh beech tree
uh
you can't predict what it's going to do
either way and
uh councillor powell is
i think is quite right
it would be a shame to bring it down
we've got
uh
mr brabing who's obviously having uh
well he's not happy about the size of
the tree
i was uh once
uh at a game fair
in
blenheim park
and all the trees were oak trees and
they were all numbered and the health
and safety people had been around and
inspected the trees and also the
arborologists
and they said yep they're all okay and
these trees were inspected
uh very frequently
and
during the night the night of the show
one came down and it missed somebody's
caravan by a few inches
for no reason whatsoever
so
it's a bit of a belt and braces job
but
i think basically the safety of the tree
uh
is in question
and
it's a brave man who can say this tree
isn't going to come down
i wouldn't like to see it come down
because it's been there for years
uh but also the walls not safe as it is
so that needs to be seen
but
you know hand on heart you've got to
think about
this tree
and if it comes down
and yeah it's been there for all these
years whether it's out
grown its life or whatever i don't know
i don't really want to make a decision
for it to stay there i'm sorry uh you
know my conscience is there and i have
all the sympathy for peter brabbing who
lives in the vicinity and i know other
people
will be the same but just
ask yourself this how would you feel you
know we had
a minute silence for somebody or some
people at kellerman
would you like a minute silence for
somebody killed by that tree when you
made the decision
so
yes they can replace it and it may be a
few years before it's in action but
you know and on heart
uh make the decision and see what you
think
we had an independent uh arborologist do
uh there was a similar argument about
trees if they're gonna be
fell or not
and it was at anchorbold road
if uh
councillor hancock
remembers and we decided to uh well the
planning officer wanted to fill them all
with tpos on them
and the independent chap
came and gave his thing and said well
some of them are and some of them aren't
uh and we ended up keeping so many but
there you
are i'll leave it up to you and your
conscience
i prefer a belt
counselor
councillor cooper
i've got to say that i agree with uh
councilor armitage and council elliot um
we've heard from uh richard purcell
councillor foster raised it we've had
the
specialist report from from our own
staff if we're not going to accept that
then why are we asking them in the first
place i'll leave it to that
well we did have a motion
put on the table
and i didn't see a second was there a
second abuse
as i had it it was um councillor um
ridgeway and hancock all right sorry i
beg your pardon
so
and that's the only motion which is on
the table at the moment there hasn't
been an amendment and it's not been
withdrawn
this was the motion to defer whilst
further information was uh
okay so roll call
thank you members
so um i'll now commence the roll call if
you could clearly say fought against or
a stain on the motion to defer the
application
cather armitage
engaged
councillor cooper against
councillor elliott
council foster against
councillor hall
four
councillor hancock
four
council heartshawn
against
cather jones
for
councillor liggett abstain
castle powell
against castle ridge bay
for
councillor rouse
and councillor ralph against
that's five votes for seven against with
one abstention so the motion falls chair
thank you i'm going to put a motion to
the floor now is that we actually accept
the recommendation by our officers hand
on heart i know it's an extremely
difficult decision for us all
but first and foremost i don't want to
be sitting here in six months six years
or whatever
but that's the motion i put on the floor
is there a seconder
thank you chair would you be open to an
amendment
um because as i said i'm comfortable
dealing with the one beach that we all
have reservations about in terms of that
and the willow
but i'm not comfortable about the
pruning on the others
i'm quite happy for them to be pruned
i've seen these trees sorry david no no
that's fine
i wanted to see as it stands
[Music]
can we ask for a replacement
oh that's that's part of the condition
[Music]
that we can get yeah okay
so there we are
so that's to uh approve officer
recommendations
with emphasis in the conditions that uh
suitable replacement trees be put in
their place
yes
okay thank you chair
yep we can put in a management scheme so
suitable replacement trees with a
management scheme
yep
how's that um did you get that the
planning service
yeah okay thanks
thank you chair three you all commence
the vote uh councillor armitage
against
how's heart sean four
casser jones
[Music]
castle liggett four
castle powell
councillor ridgeway
i'm abstaining
council rouse
councillor rough four
[Music]
chair that is nine votes four two again
for two abstentions emotions carried
thank you thank you all and it was a
long lengthy debate thank you all
and
do we want a five minute recess before
we start item two
thank you and you may leave if you wish
break
right
we'll move on to the next application
which is 21 4 0 0 3 8 0 four slash rm
it's a reverse reserved matters
application for a single story dwelling
with rooms
in the roof percent to application
affecting the setting of a listed
building i do believe this has been
changed there aren't bedrooms in the
roof now
am i correcting that
that's correct um and i've put an update
in the late reps
okay thank you
so we'll move on and we'll ask alice to
give us a presentation and any late rep
information
oh
oh sorry
come on i shall just have to
um sorry about this
right i'll just have to flick through
right thank you chair
um
my direct members to late
representations with regards to this
application
you should have all the details in there
um
in terms of detailing this is a reserved
matters application for single-story
dwelling at cedar end wingworth hall
estate
in the case of the outline application
which was eighteen forward slash zero
zero seven zero three four o l to which
this refers the citing and access were
not reserved and the single story nature
of the proposal was agreed by condition
the site is shown here outlined in
orange with the nearby listed buildings
in blue
members of the planning committee
attended a virtual site visit of the
site where we saw a range of photographs
of the site the following are some of
the key slides
this slide shows the redline plan for
the site as approved in the outline
application
this slide shows the layout and the
access as approved in the outline
and this slide shows that the proposed
dwelling is cited as approved in the
outline
these are the front and rear elevation
drawings
members will see that the proposed
bungalow comprises two bedrooms with no
rooms in the roof the proposal is simple
in designs in design offices accept that
the design is not perhaps that which
would be expected from modern
architecture today but is heavily
influenced by the restrictions of the
outline permission and its simplicity
and lack of architectural features helps
to ensure that it would not draw the eye
from the listed building and therefore
does not harm the setting of the listed
building
this is the side elevation which shows
that the dwelling will be 6.25 meters in
height and will have a roof pitch which
is in proportion with the width of the
building
condition 7 of the outline application
prevents any installation of dormer
windows or other alterations to the roof
without the applicant applying for
planning permission
this is to protect the setting of the
listed building
following a key photographs taken from
the committee site visit which members
attended yesterday i've included these
as a refresher so this is the view from
the site
from the sighting of the house to the
north
this is the view to the east and you can
see the cedar end the listed building
itself
this is the view to the west
and this is the view to the south
there are no publicly accessible
viewpoints looking into the site
from from any of the directions
offices consider that the proposal is
acceptable for the following reasons
the proposal is cited within the area
approved by the outline the proposal is
single story as required by the outlying
permission
the proposal will not harm the setting
of the listed building due to its simple
design and modest size
the proposal will not impact the privacy
or amenity of neighbours as its location
far from neighbouring properties and
orientation looking away from
neighbouring properties does not offer
opportunities for overlooking
that concludes the presentation thank
you chair
thank you
i believe we have some speakers for this
afternoon
the first speaker is the applicant mr
armstrong
if you'd like to take a seat mr
armstrong
and you have three minutes once you're
ready
if you want to switch your microphone on
there's a little button in front of you
that's it
right of eight hours in our immediate
vicinity there's only been one objection
that from a person who was
wishing to buy the land from us
at his significant price
we have considered all points made and
have tried to come to a satisfactory
conclusion to suit all
as all permitted developments have been
withdrawn we are very aware of limited
storage space
no garage or sheds or out buildings
so therefore roof space would be a
requirement
and as no one overlooks the property i
cannot see this as a problem
the design has been accepted by
conservation and planning requirements
the landscaping will be a continuation
of our garden at cedren and will include
british species and wildflower section
in keeping with the surrounding areas
as a landscape gardener this is well
within my remit
as a person who worked for the national
trust at several of their properties
i am well aware of the need to not
intrude on the aspects of these
buildings that exist
my wife has lived there for 60 years and
is custodian of the history of the halls
having had all old photographs and
documentation bequeathed to air by mary
burton
former owner and historian
both village schools bring groups of
children here to see where the hall
stood and the site of the whole gardens
they took all the information and photos
with them to work on the history of
wingworth thanks to my wife cell
the impact on our neighbour is as
minimal as it can be anywhere
noise will be kept
to normal working hours while building
is in process
the build does not overlook any property
being screened by trees and shrubs
when mary bequeath does the land and
house it was because she knew we would
make sure the house was looked after
11 years after her death and now retired
we are making provision to continue her
legacy to restore the estate house and
generate funds to keep it as mary would
have wished
to say
thank you are there any questions
that's great thank you very much
and the second speaker is the agent
stephen bright
good afternoon
uh just like to run through the history
of the application um the proposed
development which sits within the
village envelopes seeks reserve matters
approval following the outline
permission
on december 4th of december 2018 for a
two-bed single-story detached dwelling
in the extensive grounds of cedar and
wingworth
the proposed dwelling is to be
constructed from new or reclaimed
natural stone to match the adjoining
listed buildings and boundary walls
together with a natural slate roof
the applicant mr armstrong is a retired
builder and a landscape gardener and has
many years experience in working with
natural stone for both clients
new and refurbishment projects and also
the national trust
consequently whilst the proposal is
deemed to be low-key and uninspiring by
some the finished product will sit
comfortably within the site and will be
of high quality construction which
respects the characteristics of the
locality
the design philosophy has always been to
construct a high quality dwelling that
appears to be a former stable block or
an outbuilding that has been converted
for residential use
the existing contours of the surrounding
area and the proposed finished floor
levels of the dwelling will not
adversely impact on the setting of the
surrounding listed buildings or the
trees protected by the recent
preservation order and it will blend
sensitively within the existing
landscape
the proposed dwelling adjoins the
extensive grounds of cedar end including
the small cops of trees which have been
protected by a recent preservation order
and the gardens of cedar end
are
wonderfully landscaped and provide a
haven for local wildlife
the proposed landscaping for the new
dwelling submitted with the reserve
matters application will complement this
and together with the existing retained
protected mature trees will deliver a
development that is fully sympathetic
with the locality
as members will be aware the original
outline consent eighteen forward slash
zero zero seven zero three
forward slash outline
was approved under delegated powers
and the officer report stated at the
time
i consider that a well-designed
single-story building with rooms in the
roof space would preserve the setting of
the nearby listed buildings providing
that there are no dormer windows
included in the scheme when considered
at the reserve matters stage and would
be in accordance with local planned
policy be9 of the northeast derbyshire
local plan 30 seconds remain however
following extensive discussions with the
planning department the elevations were
withdrawn from the outlying application
and the reserve matters application
revised to lower the ridge height and to
delete the rooms in the roof the
proposal before committee is for a
detached single-story two-bedroom
dwelling
in conclusion it is considered that the
development meets local plant policy
preserves and has no detrimental impact
on the setting of the nearby listed
buildings
and also provides a satisfactory design
solution which blends sensitively within
the surroundings we therefore support
the office of recommendation and commend
the proposal to the committee for your
approval
thank you are there any questions
no thank you thank you very much
at this stage are there any questions
for the planning
officer no
as you know we move
normally go on to the debate
i call this application in there is
history to it but i must admit i am very
pleased with what i've seen the officers
have worked hard
to actually deliver a single story
two-bedroomed modest dwelling
with that i'm quite happy
thank you chad i was around the back of
there last week strangely and uh yeah it
looks fantastic or it when it's actually
built in and it's in those surroundings
it's it's hidden it's going to be a
fabulous place to be
so if there's no further oh councillor
cooper
i can only add to what council elliot
said there um
i think as custodians they're doing
their utmost to uphold what's there and
not try to compete with that and that's
exactly what the
conservation officer said as well so i'm
fully supportive of this application
so with that if there's no further
questions comments i will put a motion
on that we accept this application by
the officers
thank you
roll call
thank you chair
casa armitage for
councillor cooper for councillor elliot
council foster four councillor hall
four
councillor hancock four because of heart
shawn four councillor jones for
councillor liggett for
casa powell council ridgeway four
councillor rouse
councillor four
thank you you may leave
and good luck
[Music]
so just to um and so we confirm that the
application has been approved
right final application for the
afternoon and that is for ned 21 stroke
00606 stroke tpo this is an application
to fill one ash tree covered by a tpo
number 264 t1 atlan between primary
cottage and the southeast side of
ambervale flat small road hashover for
mr d a clappman county developments
over to you alice
i'm afraid you move to dallas i just
remembered thank you
right
sorry
okay thank you chair
my first confirm that there are no late
representations been received on this
application
in terms of detailing this is a tpo
application to file one ash tree at land
between priory cottage on the southeast
side of bamberville flats moore road
ashover
the tree is located to the north of the
site and its location is outlined in
orange on this plan
members attended a spiritual site visit
of the site where we saw a range of
photographs i've included some of them
here as a refresher
this google street view image shows that
the tree was part of a pair in 2009
however its twin was already dead at the
time and had been fouled by the time the
tpo was created
it is due to having grown so close to
this twin that the tree is in the shape
it is now
this is a view from moor road the tree
in question is this one
here
the site has planning permission for
eight dwellings the tree will be located
within the garden of plot number eight
so it's here
this is the view of um
sorry this is a view of the tree from
moore road closer to ambervale flats so
it's this tree in here
and this is a close-up
of the tree you can see here that it is
lopsided and suffering from ash dieback
officers of the opinion that the
proposed filing is acceptable as the
tree's condition means it is no longer
contributes to the immunity of the area
and would pose a risk to the occupiers
of the house to be built close by
a replacement tree in the form of a
standard beach has been conditioned and
agreed by the applicant
i think um
what
having having to have the conversations
that we've had earlier
um i think you know if this tree was
still out in the field then it it it
wouldn't be an issue and we wouldn't
want to fill it but because the houses
are going to be built close to it then
it does become
a safety issue
um and uh
that
concludes the um the presentation thank
you chair
thank you we've no speakers on this
application so we'll go to questions to
the officer councillor edway um you're
saying that if this tree was in a field
then we wouldn't consider knocking it
down but yet again
planners somebody wants to build a house
or houses so the poor trees have to
suffer and be chopped down i don't
understand it i mean
can you can you give me a reason as to
you know why you agree that tree should
be knocked down so that houses can be
built the tree was there i i don't
the the um like i said if that tree was
if that field was still a field this
tree wouldn't have even come they
wouldn't have even applied would they
but because the tree is now no longer a
field um the the site has been approved
for
uh
planning for houses we do have to
consider it in
you know
in the context of it being going to be
in a garden
um and that
in that case the the owners of that that
garden will at some point if it hasn't
already died by the time the um house is
built
uh will come into to remove it so it's
the balance the
the consideration made is balancing
that
safety of those people in that house
against the condition of the tree and
the possibilities of getting a new tree
planted now
so that it's got a good chance to get
growing and be a decent size once that
house is built and people move into it
or waiting until it dies and then
they'll be able to take it down anyway
so
how do you know the person in the garden
that buys that house doesn't want that
ash tree there anyway
well they might do that
again we're here making assumptions
aren't we could we couldn't be
um i i just think again you know we've
had a long debate about trees and my my
biggest concern which i bought up to
this this council before is that we
allow you know trees to be chopped down
willy-nilly so that houses can be built
and i'm sorry i'm
it it just doesn't sit with sit
comfortable with me that
the
could i could i add a shirt um i mean
just as a sort of another way of
presenting that uh an answer to the same
point
um
if
you can see that the the tree is uh is
struggling all the other trees around it
are in full leaf but this one is really
struggling and that is
a sure sign of the
ash dieback that that it is it's having
if there were no houses being built
nearby
then this tree would just uh uh you know
die off and eventually fall down safely
in a
in a field
but um the application is now to uh uh
take the tree down in a safe manner so
that when there are houses nearby it's
not just going to fall down and land on
a house or land on people in the garden
so that that's that's the reason why um
the
uh there's a difference between what the
situation is now and if the if there
were no
um houses being built there
in the uh
as the situation is
councillor foster
thank you chair yeah just for the record
this council doesn't allow trees to be
cut down willy-nilly
the officers don't and this committee
doesn't so that's for the record
thank you and i agree wholeheartedly
with you but i would like to point out
too in our papers page 53
it does clearly state the scheme of
replacement and that these trees will be
replaced with mature trees
so hopefully we would take that into
consideration as well they're not just
being cut down i've seen this tree it is
suffering greatly from ash dieback the
last thing we want is for it to spread
so unfortunately
um i have to support the officers but
moving on councillor armitage then
councillor jones
hi uh thank you chap i
had a look at this tree yesterday uh
i've seen it
previously but
it is it's definitely got ash die back
uh
it will spread it's throughout the
village there are many trees now got it
i cannot see that
you know
i think six months time that tree could
be completely dead
uh that's the rate at which it's
spreading
i agree uh
with the
mark foster we don't cut them down
willy-nilly but they are diseased and as
such they it should be taken down and
a new tree put there a reasonable size
not a sapling and with the management
plan as we did in the last one
and these should be adhered to
i don't like seeing trees cut down they
take a long time to grow
but on this occasion
you know it's it's there and one of the
worst things you can do
is try and fell a tree that's dead uh
i've done it myself and i was looking to
get away with my life because
what they do they tend to snap off
halfway up and drop on you and i've been
just missed by one
so that's my personal view
put it down
and replace it with a decent tree not a
sapling
any other comments counselor elliot
councillor jones yeah this one's a bit
easier for me chair because it is
actually suffering with disease i i
don't have any issue and if you read
through the bump then it does say they
will replace it with mature trees
not one tree so no issue with that and
it does say that they will let us know
the split size and the type and the
species and so on before they do that so
i have no issue with this one thank you
what i'm concerned about is um
what they can replace it with and
they're saying it's going to be a beach
we've seen the size that beaches grow to
so in
10 15 20 years somebody will be wanting
to cut that down because it's in the
garden and it's too big and it's
overshadowing the house
i think we need to look at what it's
replaced with that they're going to be
a proper size and that there's going to
be enough to replace
that plant that built that um tree
for as regards to its
use
in the planet uh conservation stuff
i'm just not happy about as cutting
trees down i do know this is is diseased
i accept that
but i just think it's stupid to put
something in that's going to end up
having the same conversation about in 10
years time when it's overgrown where it
is
um
that's brilliant
as i said if you read the lit in
literature on it it does say that they
are putting the one standard beach back
but they are also putting mature trees
back of different varieties as well so
and they're going to come to us with
that before they fell this one so maybe
if you want to stipulate what you want
in there
they i assume we'll put in native trees
thank you just
i know about beach trees i've got them
right near my house and they're huge
and they're beautiful
and they have you know birds and
everything everything about them i
really appreciate them and i know this
ash tree is dying and i can see that it
should be taken down
but
in your own garden you won't want a
beach the size of the ones that grow
near me
and i just think in time people will be
saying oh it's overshadowing our house
and it's doing this that and the other
it's breaking our patio up and
everything
and
i think we should look at what we plant
there so it's appropriate and if you're
going to plant more trees
fair enough
and it's quite clearly stipulated on
page 53 again what they're going to be
doing and not doing so i'm quite happy
with what's actually proposed councillor
foster thank you chair for giving me i'm
not sure what which part of the
agenda we're at here are we able to put
our
emotions forward yet we're at that
position here unless anyone's got any
other questions to the officer i'm quite
happy to do that because i think we've
spent long enough here to do that i
propose that we go with officers
recommendations on this yeah thank you
um roll call
thank you chair
casa armitage for councillor cooper
councillor elliott
council foster four councillor hall
four councillor hancock four council
hearts on four council jones four
council liggett for council powell
council ridgeway here for
casa raos
and councillor
for
the caricature
okay brings us on to item 8 planning
appeals lodged and determined richard
are you going to lead on this
well all i've
got to say really is that you've you've
got the um the report there a couple of
uh appeal decisions that you've had in
you've already had the uh
um
the actual decision letters sent to you
if you have any questions well happy to
ask but they're fairly um
uh
minor um
applications
um and um
uh if you've had enough of talking about
trees then you might want to pass over
the one from uh holy moore side but um
if you're on a roll and want to talk
about that as well then um
uh
happy to
uh have that discussion the other one is
in relation to
uh just um house extensions
uh
avocado are there any questions for
richard
thank you
everyone happy with that
all right thank you
and the last item matters of urgency i
have got absolutely no matters right
starting blocks are all off
thank you all very much
you